[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
always great to talk some baseball with
Tim kirchen Hall of Famer and part of
ESPN's uh baseball London broadcast
there with Michael K and Alex Rodriguez
contributor to baseball tonight before
we get started we just played a clip
from Dennis Rodman saying if Larry Bird
played in today's NBA he wouldn't be in
the NBA he would be in Europe I know you
uh love your basketball
what do you make of Dennis Rodman's
comments
well that's absolutely Preposterous Dan
Larry Bird's great player in any era he
would be a great player today when he
recognized how important the three-point
shot is in today's game he would be
after Steph Curry and maybe Klay
Thompson the best three-point shooter in
the game he is a top 10 basketball
player of all time he's one of the great
interior passers I've ever seen in my
life
he would be so good today because people
don't play the game like he played it
back then go look at those I know you
have those highlights of Larry's
greatest passes back then they all led
to a dunk or a layup for the chief and
Kevin kale he was a genius at this game
he would have been a he would be a star
today like he was a star back then yeah
and I know Dennis is just trolling us
and you go back to when the Pistons been
Larry with no athleticism stole the ball
the inbounds pass from Isaiah and fed it
to DJ and having been there at the
Garden when Dennis said if he was a
black player he'd be just another uh
player if he were a black player and I
went and Dennis is great at getting
attention so I think that's what he's
doing here but I thought I would ask you
being a big basketball fan yeah sorry
Dan I just always loved it that Larry
used to
uh oh
Tim just froze up
either that or it's a dramatic pause see
if we can get uh Timmy back here
Tim can you hear me
yeah I can hear you Dan sorry I've had
computer problems all morning okay so
bad at technology I'm sorry you were
going to say that you loved that bird
would what
he would he would call Madison Square
Garden a gym I love shooting in that gym
everything was just a gym to him which
is why he was so great because it was
when he was 16 years old shooting in a
gym 18 shooting in the gym Madison
Square Garden was a gym to him and
that's another reason to love Larry Bird
he's Tim kirchen Hall of Fame baseball
writer for the mothership what was the
I'm not going to say end game but
baseball in London
why
well baseball's trying to globalize
itself and it was a great atmosphere
there Dan it was tremendous uh 54 000
people were there and granted there were
a lot of cubs fans and a lot of carton
fans there but there were a lot of
people in Great Britain that are
starting to get interested in baseball
it's going to take some time it's a
soccer country obviously but whenever
you can put on a game with that monk
energy to it and both games were like
that it's good for the game and again it
doesn't mean that you know we're going
to have a team in London within five
years or that the Brits are going to
love baseball within the next 10 years
but it's always good to take the game
somewhere else and I was really struck
Band by how many players on each team
really enjoyed the experience beyond the
baseball field they went to you know
Tower of London they went to
you know Westminster Abbey they went to
Buckingham Palace and I talked to 20
different players and they were all
dazzled by the history of London it was
like I wasn't even talking to baseball
players at certain points Paul the young
shortstop for the Cardinals maybe after
a while and he goes you know isn't it
amazing because they took a trip down
the River Thames on a on a boat he said
isn't it amazing how every great
civilization is built on a river believe
me you don't hear that from too many
shortstops in the big leagues but I I
really enjoyed it and I really enjoyed
talking to Miles Michaelis about this he
went to Westminster Abbey he said that
place is the thousand years old and it's
way better built than what we build
anywhere today so it was a really good
experience for everyone I thought and I
was it was refreshing to me to talk to
baseball players about something other
than baseball the Aaron judge injury is
puzzling because when he got hurt and
then they thought he was going to be
back a couple of days later and it was a
strained toe then we realized that it's
far more serious
wouldn't the MRI have shown that when
the swelling went down that this is far
more severe uh did the Yankees hide this
for any reason
I I don't think they hid anything I just
don't think they knew the severity of it
I mean this toe injury I'm not sure
we've ever heard of an injury quite like
this but I think it speaks again to how
easily you can get hurt playing baseball
and given the degree of difficulty of
the game if your feet aren't working
properly you're not going to be able to
play the game and just another reminder
this game is not built for someone who's
six seven two eighty two and when he
suffers an injury like this I I have to
think it's it's going to be even worse
than say if someone my size got the same
injury because there's so many more
moving parts to Aaron judge but this is
a serious situation he I think he'll
play again this year I just don't know
when it's going to be and this is just
another reminder of how different a club
they are yeah when he doesn't play
they're a completely different team when
he doesn't play yeah and then you look
at this team that they they built and
then you realize are they a house of
cards because you don't have Aaron judge
in there then everybody else falls apart
you know the Giancarlo Stanton contract
was horrible Josh Donaldson and some of
these other players they've kind of
thrown in there and you then you start
to think of the value of Aaron judge uh
you know shohei is probably the most
valuable player but what judge means to
the Yankees man that's pretty surprising
that they fall apart we're talking to
Tim kirchen ESPN baseball analysts we
were talking about the College World
Series and the aluminum bats I don't
know if you're a fan or not I'm not I
don't like the Ping but the cost of
those bats is that really what it comes
down to that's why we have aluminum bats
in uh in college
yes absolutely that's to me the only
reason why and I'm sorry I'm with you
Dan I just don't get it this is an
exceptionally high level of baseball
they should be using wood bats you know
I have a there's a Sandlot team in the
Cal Ripken league that plays 20 minutes
from my house called the big train and
they use wood bats in summer because
that's what they should be wearing using
but just keep in mind
Pete cavilia once told me that he broke
144 bats in one season he went through
12. doesn't bats he you know he used a
bat with a really skinny handle and a
barrel the size of a canned ham so he
could swing as fast as he could and he
just overpowered his own bat
to play for the Brewers BJ serov told me
he broke five bats in one day he he made
it out and broke it like several times
during a game and then he came back and
just snapped one in half at the bat rack
because he was so upset bats break very
easily but and so I think that's it I
think it's the cost more than anything
else because a good aluminum bat can
last a long time I also wondered about
this we may have seen the two or three
best players in this draft coming up in
the College World Series but we rarely
hand off the Baton for somebody in
college College World Series and then
they go right into you know the Brewers
starting lineup you know they're going
to be gone for a couple of years in the
miners and then coming back up I'm
guessing with with some of these players
they don't they're not able to take
advantage of this platform here and you
go I can't wait to see that guy you know
playing in the majors in a couple of
weeks
yeah but again Dan this is why we love
baseball so much it is so damn hard to
play that even if you're a dominant
player in a division one program the
best program in the country that doesn't
mean you're going to step into the big
leagues and suddenly be good I mean it's
happened before Bob Horner didn't go to
you know just went straight from college
to the big leagues and was a great
hitter and there are other instances of
that but it just shows you if if you're
a cornerback in Michigan and you weigh
220 and you love to hit people and you
can run you can play the NFL the next
year it doesn't work that way in
baseball because of the degree of
difficulty of the game and that's why I
love it so much is it takes time in the
minor leagues in order to be good enough
to play in the big leagues and that's
just not exactly the same as it is in
basketball and football if you ran the
angels
at what point do you consider trading
show hey Otani if at all
uh uh I don't consider it at all unless
they are hopelessly out of the playoff
race at the end of July and I don't
think they're going to be their only
hope is to try to make the playoffs with
him and convince him look we made the
playoffs and we're going to make the
playoffs again next year now I'm not
suggesting that's going to happen but
they have to convince him we're gonna
win here also keep in mind Dan with him
he's he is obsessed with winning of
course he's also obsessed with his own
numbers and he's also obsessed with the
Comfort level on where he is playing if
he's not comfortable playing in a
certain place like his career average at
Yankee Stadium small state not good and
if he doesn't feel comfortable hitting
at some ballpark or pitching in another
ballpark he may he may rule that place
out he's very comfortable with the
angels and I'm not suggesting he's going
back to the angels but he sure loves to
hit and pitch in that ballpark and there
is something to that yeah the downside
is though they could lose him for
nothing
right and again this is why we need to
ask this question every day for the rest
of the season and until the day he signs
what do the Angels do I've never seen
anything quite like this you can't just
lose it for a draft choice and yet you
can't trade him if there's any chance
you can keep him that's the real tricky
part about this
great to talk to you again Timmy thanks
for joining us
okay Dan see you soon that's Tim kirchen
ESPN baseball analyst and he is a
Baseball Hall of Famer